my guest tonight is a very funny
comedian and actor who won an emmy for
his portrayal of zach galifianak's mom
christine in baskets
now you can see him in the film coming
to america
on amazon prime video please welcome i
love this guy
louis anderson louie good to see you
what's up
hi conan uh nice to talk to you now
where are you right now louie
i am in henderson nevada okay
and right out of las vegas okay and are
you alone or are you are you
quarantining with somebody
well i'm there's one other person here i
half of the time i'm me and the other
half
i'm this person and uh
you put you put on the wig i put on the
wig
i put on the schmuck you put a schmack
on yeah
that seems pandemicky so it's very nice
so you can be the character you are
in baskets you just put on a wig and
then you can just hang out with each
other
yeah we talk how are you louie
i don't know
so it's kind of that kind of thing yeah
my mom was notorious
for going mom how are you i guess i'm
okay
oh god so you just sit down because it
was gonna be a while from then on
yeah it kind of takes the energy out of
the room um out of the universe
just hard to do now was it did you get
vaccinated you got vaccinated i
did i just got my second shot right
and uh god just right after i got it
maybe an hour
i started nauseated i was feeling sick
i called the doctor i go can it happen
that fast and then i went oh wait
i did stop and get white castle
that could have been
now are you taking care of yourself
because you you look good
are you taking care of yourself are you
are you being healthy are you living
healthy
you know it's such a relative statement
isn't it when people say that what i'm
you know i started the pandemic at about
378 or 80 pounds
depending on what i was leaning on
and now i'm uh 3 40.
oh good for you i'm trying to get to 275
so i can get into some of my mom's
actual clothes
i got to tell you louis you're killing
backstage here there's like
there's like four people back here that
are laughing out loud very funny it's a
start
yeah but we gotta build back so yeah so
that's better
you're gonna build back better you're
you're losing
weight
you know one minute i'm eating the next
minute i'm not
and i take another minute off i figure
that way i'm only eating 30 minutes
out of a 60 which is half so i'm getting
i'm trying to get down to four to 40 20.
you know i'm not eating for 40 and then
i'm eating for 20.
no it's a wonderful thing the
intermittent fasting intermittent
that's a rough one for a midwesterner
yeah you know i just realized that you
just
you have a better version of my hair
this was this was expensive this was yes
like mine is
i've this whole i i i'm able to rent
this out for corn and wheat
[Laughter]
now what's going to happen i i just
thought of something
that i'm concerned about which is you've
spent a career
telling really funny jokes about being
heavy
what do you do you're losing weight
you're going to get down to this goal
weight of 275
are you going to retire those jokes i'm
thinking
yes i'm going to retire my fat jokes
um and then you know i think i'll always
be funny but
you know i can't remember doing my first
jokes and
i did 1978. uh i sound 100 years old
saying that but
um my first joke you know i um
i i walked up on stage and i go i can't
stay long i'm in between meals
and it got a big laugh that's the first
joke you try out
yeah and then i said i was uh when i was
born i weighed 60 pounds the doctor had
to bring a crane in to slap my ass
so you you hit on this idea early and
you went with it
yeah i was a breastfed baby my mom went
dry
okay come on all right
they're not appropriate but listen this
is why i'm retiring now
yeah maybe you could have retired these
are one more one more
one more one more little run that i love
do you mind if i do it no
go ahead all right i was in the fat
olympics
i uh that pole vault i drove that sucker
right into the ground
[Laughter]
i did a good thing though i straightened
out those uneven parallel bars
and this is a very inappropriate which
one this is the one
that cracked up johnny carson broad jump
killed her
i apologize to all you women out there
no no no it's fine you mean it in
in the best way
[Laughter]
what about you know you talk a lot about
your mom you've already spoken about her
yeah what was your favorite jokes about
your mom
because you you've gotten a lot of
mileage out of your mom over the years
yeah
she's you know my mom she was such a
funny person but didn't know it you know
people like that where you go you're so
funny
how can i use this to my advantage and
she'd walk into a restaurant first words
out of her mouth
could we get some extra butter and the
waiter would say well let us seat your
party first
yeah she loved her butter a lot of
babies when they're born they're
powdered i was buttered
i was slippery but a lot of fun
[Laughter]
you know my mom though she just was a
she was a lovely person you would have
loved it and you know she
got to see a lot of my stand up and you
know
i talk about my dad she'd rub her arms
and
she would have been great in the
pandemic i would have loved to
my mom in the pandemic just hang out
with her
well first of all she'd be so thrilled
my hands were this clean
yeah my hands you know because she was
the kind of person
if your hands were dirty she would come
to where you're sitting bring a bowl of
soapy water and a cloth
and wash her she was our own mother
teresa yeah but it sounds like she was
into this
she was into people washing their hands
long before the pandemic
she was she was ahead of her time what
can i say and they imagine the food we'd
have
yeah i i mean you'd always you hungry
we just ate well you look a little
hungry
you know my mom that's the reason i'm
you know we
traced her uh ancestry back to the
mayflower
and that's why i have such a bread
problem okay
right i don't know i just like that i
know it's funny but you have jokes that
you like that never work
yes have you not seen me perform
yes but i have a lot of jokes i do that
i'm
that i like that maybe the crowd doesn't
like
but if it makes who cares but if it
makes me laugh it's like a gift to
myself
yes like every time i'm in california
i'm performing i go i just was in
a thousand oaks but i only counted
around 900 of them
never get never but i do it
i am committed to that joke i will do it
over
and over and over i'm curious about
something what was your mom's
reaction to your stand up did she she
must been very proud of you which did
she like that you did
did stand up she hate she didn't well
she would be sad when i do stuff about
my dad because she missed them
uh but when i would do her she'd go
louie
you've got a cute act thank you mother
it's the last thing a comic wants to
hear
a yeah uh you're pretty good
no um and uh she said but you're doing
me all wrong
i go what do you mean i don't do that i
do more of
this i go what is that well that's just
my thing
and i go uh i just love you mom because
you're so insane
and you're just uh you know she just was
so funny
like and she was she didn't she have any
idea she was funny
yeah you know if the car door slammed
she was a window monitor you know what
that is don't you no
car door slam she's right over there oh
um oh the johnsons are home
that oldest kid's on a drugs i think
and my dad would get so mad he go oh
look at your mother you know the fbi
don't
they don't even question people anymore
they just call your mother
and my mom would be oh
she had the best hmm interesting always
a bad story with your mom
when my with my mom when i'd show up how
are you bomb
well i'm okay
what do you hear about shirley
you're not even sure who shirley is
really
she fell then she'd look at me like i
had something to do with it
let me ask you about in coming to
america this is a fantastic story
because
the original movie was so long ago and
um now they've they've done a remake and
you're in it
which is fantastic all the original
people came back
i'm curious how did you get cast in the
first movie and the first coming to
america how did that come about
well i didn't know this i thought
i had bought eddie a dinner with his
entourage at the
at the ivy one time i just told the
waiter put it on
my american express and i'll try to work
it off
and um because it was a lot of it was
like 660 dollars i remember that
and that was in the 40s so
[Laughter]
the war had just ended yeah and then
later
now i just find out eddie had to hire me
because paramount i guess
said you have to have a white person in
the movie
and i go ah i'm a token white guy yeah
and he said he did nice he gave me some
nice props about
i the only the funniest white guy i know
as louis anderson
but um i had no idea for 33 years
i thought i did something nice and
that's what did it but
the real truth is eddie did something
nice
and and you know people have tried to
start a deal about it and i go i like
being a token white guy
yeah i don't mind it nothing i mean i'm
as
white i am this you got in rich flower
you got louie you got other i mean i i
disappear in a snowstorm yeah i don't
know i'm pretty
white myself louis you are you're a
little off-white though
well you've known eddie since you knew
eddie murphy in the 80s when you guys
were both doing stand-up together
right the comedy star yeah um arsenio
eddie that eddie would come in
and you know i'm backstage and people go
do you mind if eddie does a set tonight
i go
eddie who no um but you knew who eddie
was when he gets like when they said
richard's here
yeah same thing or if they said robin's
here right
you know he and i he goes eddie's going
to go on next and i go oh
jesus you know and he go out he crushed
the room
he just crushed it was like demolished
yeah people were like
jump you know people he killed it yeah
and you know then i got to go out he's
talking about
i got to go i'm doing jokes about butter
he's doing jokes about ralph cramden
having sex with norton
yeah yeah yeah and i'm going down and go
where are you going folks yeah uh
i'm hoping that we'll get you know i uh
when i was there
i talked to him about him doing his
stand up you mean just recently you
talked about recently
when you were hanging out with eddie
doing the movie you talked to him about
doing stand-up
i was hanging out with him and i said
i heard you're working on stand-up
because i had heard he did dolomite
coming to america and then he was going
out on tour well then
you know our lives changed and he said i
don't know
i go well you know he goes i i think i'd
be pretty r i said
you pick right up you you would i at
first joke and boom you're on your way
oh he thought he'd be too rusty to do it
he said i i'm gonna be too rusty i'm
gonna
i go listen why don't you do this why
don't you open
a couple of my shows for me you know
i'll take it easy on you you take it
easy
but you know i'm hoping that he does a
tour with the coming you know there are
do you know how many
stand-up comics are in that movie yes
it's impressive
it's amazing and um i want to i'll just
be the mc i'll be the token white
emcee so you're saying a coming to
america comedy tour where it's all the
comedians that are in the movie
including eddie right and then you
have to listen we have to have eddie
yeah
i think eddie otherwise it's just these
guys yeah
no it's eddie and then the other guys
but you'd be
you'd be the mc i think that'd be good
for me
here he is anybody
yeah it would be so much fun listen what
would be more fun
yeah than um than going out on that kind
of tour
well i have to say i i i know you're the
same way but
um i live for being in front of people i
just love it
and uh it's i would say it's the thing
i've missed the most
you know in the last year is is
being in front of people and and and
hearing them occasionally laugh
you know that's how you're i mean
this is what we were made for yeah you
know it's just a shame we couldn't have
been in front of those people during
this
tough time but i did do a show
uh the day after thanksgiving it was uh
you know social distance
and everyone had to wear a mask and get
their temperature
and it was outside but i look forward to
it
what about you andy and me going on tour
oh the three incredibly white guys yeah
the three tokens
like the pips kind of the pips the white
version of the pips
the white pips yeah yeah i uh
i man i mean between the three of us
andy has the most
color you know andy's got actually no
andy's are really
i mean he hardly fits into this no next
to me he is
he looks cuban next to me he's uh yeah
he's but he does
um so god bless him but yeah i uh people
i look unwell most of the time you look
unwell i
i mean people don't you know when you
are like i've had people say that to me
are you okay oh yeah and you know what i
say are you okay
that's right are you okay yeah but it's
your doctor it's your doctor
asking you louise this is my doctor
you and your doctor says how you feeling
lou you're like feeling joking
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know what's so funny i've never it's
never been easier to look at an adult
and imagine them as a baby
as you it's that head
on a baby's body the same teeth
i have the same teeth as a baby how much
do you love
coffee during the pandemic oh i love
coffee
coffees yeah i go to a place called
coffee class
now that's the way i got they got me
they said
they called their place coffee class i
go you know because my mom would always
say you know that guy uh he's got a lot
of class
i go what does that mean you know he's
just well look at him he's with
it so my mom was kind of you know she
married a jazz musician
so my mom was i go why'd you marry dad
the curls i go mother
oh i really miss i really miss you know
what's so great
my mom did the one most wonderful thing
for me
she gave me a running monologue in my
head
that i get to have every day and my
dad's in there too
shut up
that's where i got that thing from
baskets yeah
yep yep
i missed that i really miss being from a
family of
11 i miss yelling oh that's right you're
from a family of 11.
yeah and you know i like sometimes i'm
in this house you know with christine
she's in the bathroom right now
but um i'll just go and be careful sound
guys um
she'll i'll just go shut up
[Laughter]
because you need it yeah don't you think
people need it i do
i do we need that we need to be have
voices in our head yelling
shut up all the time i must seem a
little crazy because not at all
oh please no i don't know i'm so happy
you know like
i'm happy you know what we get happiest
about i know you know this
when someone offers us a job like you
said hey will you come on
to my show and i go uh i guess
yeah no i was very excited okay
raise the level like this is what i've
been telling people from the moment i
found out i go i'm i'm on conan
no nice what i'm on conan
is he's still on
and then you say technically yeah no i i
absolutely adore you and um
you know one of the all-time good guys
nice guys
great interviewer and self-depreciator
your self-depreciate you know like
you or i can't we won't take a
compliment right no
people learned a long time ago don't
compliment me i'll take your head off
so oh yeah it's a really pleasant
pleasant person to be around
i will just take your fish sticks
[Laughter]
look we have a clip here from coming to
america too
no you're not in it what's the point
let's take a look at this clip take a
look
the mcdowell's making is in no way
influenced by the mcdonald's menu
they've got egg mcmuffins
we got egg mcstuffins we are also
celebrating the arrival of our new
beyond big mcburger
and it's all part of my lovely
granddaughter's campaign to reduce our
uh
uh carbon footprint and without using
any animal byproducts it's just good
old-fashioned grass
so there's no meat there's no meat
beautiful leafy taste
that's not gonna work that's not gonna
that burger is not going to sell have
you had an impossible burger
i've had them it's good every human
being now
is forced to eat food with vegans
[Laughter]
you know that's true yes hey hey uh
carl's coming
so we're gonna make a vegan thing oh
forgot
i'm gonna eat something before they get
here yeah i'm going to eat a few try me
up some liver
and onions i want the
stench of meat to at least be in the
room
[Laughter]
i mean i've had a stuff where i go oh
you sure
this you know just to humor them oh are
you sure there's no meat in this
of course you can tell whether because i
start growling when i
when i know but you bite into that you
go oh
sassafras is that sassafras in there
yeah
no it's a hell it's i i'm i'm a steak
and potatoes guy
but sadly that's how i was wrong so i'm
a steak potatoes
and a seven layer something
you want seven layers of steak and
potato i understand that
yes and i've been watching
the great britain baking show oh great
british baking show yeah
yes british sorry that's all right you
know what's good about that show is
what i think i might like tiramisu now
they talked you into it right you just
said oh that's a
tiramisu with a chocolate frog huh
i i've really enjoyed uh all the great
television out there
yeah it's a golden age right now there's
a lot of great entertainment
right now platinum i'd say
well i'm just trying to be progressive
all right coming to america is available
on amazon prime video
louie number one yeah download
2021 really yes that's
that's pretty good uh yeah there's no do
it there's no better
than that one is the top that's the best
one is the top
all right louie thank you for doing it
you're hilarious and i can't wait
time i'm always available to be your
roving
las vegas reporter okay
i would just be roving around my house i
know you you're not you don't want a
grove who wants to rove
uh i don't uh you take care louis you
too